Okay.
So how did your work on disgust changed
the way that you looked at things?
Fundamentally mean you gave
some indication of that already,
but what else has changed?
So since I was coming out of a,
of a psychological literature
that was very focused on,
on sort of secular,
secular ethics about justice and fairness,
and then I began studying,
discussed and looking at the broader
moral domain that almost all societies
have,
that then also led me to think about,
well,
okay,
if disgust is a reaction to
things that seem to be degrading.
So an interesting element of discusses
this notion of degradation that there are
always these vertical metaphors.
Um,
uh,
image discussed,
brings us down and discussed it.
So a lot of some religious practice in
Judaism and Islam and Hinduism is about
preparing your body to
approach God and uh,
purification.
And so that led me to think,
well,
if there's an emotion which is about
seeing our lower base or animal biological
nature,
is there an opposite emotion?
Is there an emotion that we feel when
we see some manifestation of a higher
nobler nature?
And I was just beginning to think this,
when I moved to Uva,
I got my first job at University
of Virginia in 1995 and I read,
uh,
the set of Thomas Jefferson's letters.
And in one letter he describes,
he describes the feelings you
get from reading great fiction.
He advises a cousin of his that he
should buy fiction for his library,
not just,
you know,
serious works of law and philosophy.
And he described,
he says,
Eh,
doesn't,
uh,
he,
he describes the feeling of,
of,
uh,
of uh,
having your sentiments be elevated.
Does it not dilate your breast or giving
an open feeling in your chest when you
see these acts of beauty
and kindness and gratitude?
I thought,
wow,
that's exactly yet.
Um,
and so because I've
been studying discussed,
I then started studying its opposite,
which I and some others
called moral elevation.
So this is kind of vertical metaphor of
elevation and degradation and it snaps
onto the body too with regards to,
that's right.
High Low,
uh,
clean,
dirty.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's a beautiful pairing.
And so having this language of elevation
and discussed just really has helped me
see a lot of things.
I just,
I can just see a lot of things happening.
It allows me to,
like,
even in,
you know,
manipulate,
like of applying for a grant proposal.
Like it I can get very good at like
having an elevating ending and you know,
to,
um,
uh,
to end with a note of uplift.
Um,
and so it just brought it,
it just broadened my
thinking about morality.
And this was around 1995 and so again,
it just prepared me so that,
um,
uh,
and I'd already been
to India by that point.
I spent three months doing research in,
in Orissa,
in eastern India.
Um,
so it just broadened my thinking and
that's what allowed me finally to
understand conservatives because
I had always been on the left.
I hated Ronald Reagan.
Um,
I thought Republicans were stupid and
evil and it was only when I had gone to
India and really tried to
understand a traditional religious,
hierarchical gender stratified society.
Tried to understand it in their terms.
They didn't try to just bring in my own,
my own western left,
you know,
left leaning perspectives.
Um,
that I was,
and this was all under the guidance of
Richard Suede or my postdoc supervisor at
the University of Chicago.
We did a post doc.
Um,
it was only then that he was able to,
to,
to sort of get inside their minds and
their moral system and see that there were
alternative moral worlds.
They each had their own logic and
that was the metaphor I came to it.
You know,
at the time,
you know,
the matrix movies were very popular.
So the metaphor,
the Matrix as a consensual
hallucination made a lot of sense.
It's waking up with the idea of just
speaking about moral matrices have a
different moral matrix,
better grounded in biology and biology
in the sense that it gives us the
potential.
It's like the building blocks of this
matrix can't be just anything that comes,
it comes from our experiences,
our embodied experiences.
And again,
George Lakoff is the,
is the master of,
of,
of that thinking.
And so it was only then that I was able
to now listen to conservative talk radio
and Christian religious radio and see,
rather than just saying,
oh that was stupid terrible.
People say like,
Oh wow,
yeah,
I can see that they're
striving for certain versions.
Right.
So you started to understand their
metaphorical language essentially.
That's right.
And that was like kind of like my,
you know,
on a great awakening or
scales falling from my eyes.
But you know,
since well it took a few more,
it took a number of a lot more years.
But eventually I kinda just like pulled
out the implants from my eyes and I
stopped seeing everything through a
partisan lens and I'm not on any side now.
I'm just trying to
understand what that is.
Well,
it's really useful.
It's really useful to understand that
there are actual reasons why people see
the world differently and that you can't
just easily say that one is right and
the other is wrong because the liberals
are correct when it comes to borders,
that if you thicken them too much
and diminish the information flow,
you risk making the society so
static that any radical environmental
transformation will sink it.
It's the case,
but the conservatives are right in that
you pay a big price with regards to
newcomers and new information with regards
to risk to exposure to contaminating
while to contamination period,
but also to contaminating ideas.
And so then I've always thought,
you know,
the,
the environment itself moves back
and forth like a snake in some sense.
And what we're trying to do is
stay on the center of its back.
And the only way we can
do that is by people,
by having people pull
to the right and say,
be careful.
And people pull to the left and say,
well,
yeah,
but be open with that dialogue and the,
the exchange of information
that that dialogue allows,
we can maybe specify the center of that
moving target and stay and stay well and
stay on the back.
Let's,
yeah.
Okay.
So that's a really complicated
metaphor with the snake,
but I think it's,
it's,
it's a perfect way in to what's going
on on campus and to why viewpoint
diversity is so important.